[Musique]
r
je suis venu à la pêche aux informations
il faut impérativement que jamais de
cette bien on est en france et donc ne
sache qu'on vous en fait
c'est quoi ça mon coeur de quoi bel
accueil mais j'essaie pachon sétois
bâton mais pas une cuve comme ça par
terre non c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi
écoutez moi je viens d autres foncent et
normalement les l'hérault de la bière
c'est nous ok qu'est ce que j'apprends
là qu'est ce que j'apprends que ici un
pire en eure-et-loir flou et amélie ont
créé détiennent la meilleure bière
blanche du monde sait ça
c'est quoi la technique ok on va
disputer
ok générique
wanadoo et voilà la fameuse bière la
championne a en fait c'est
la bière qui a gagné le trophée c'est le
trophée de la meilleure bière tout pays
toutes catégories confondues au concours
international de lyon au fait vous avez
quand même ramener la coupe à la maison
ram n at-on pas la maison allait ramener
la coupe à la maison alors à dessus qui
m'interpelle chez vous c'est quand même
le parcours de vie atypique ancien
cuisinier ancien prof d'anglais oui oui
brise brian in the kitchen et blink
boire de la bière cette envie de vous
lancer dans cette aventure commencée
venus ont déjà j'étais amateur de bière
j'ai aimé ça et donc avec un ami on sait
c'est une affaire de la bière et par
chance notre première pierre fut mal
donc on a un amant conceptualiser la
brasserie on voulant créer une petite
unité de manière assez anonyme on t'a
donné à minima sur un terrain voyez vous
mêmes salut par semaine depuis la
victoire des champions du monde vous
êtes champions quand même un choc on est
tous ensemble c'est le bonheur la bière
est debout là ça tombe très bien la
vierge goût parce que beaucoup ne savent
pas que la bière artisanale se
conservent deux bouts et si vous la
mettez temps chez dans le frigo vous
risquez d'avoir un geyser à l'ouverture
il faut toujours à conserver de buka
soit en cave ou dans le frigo c'est sa
france 3 sont au val de loire on donne
deux n'est pas là pour réguler
le lieu le décor là la vie ici vous
inspirer pour le côté artistique aussi
de vos bières on est à un client et
ennemi du château de maintenon et quand
même au château de maintenon il ya un
truc un peu incroyable c'est l'histoire
d'amour entre madame de maintenon et une
14 qui finit par un mariage secret parce
qu'elle était pas noble elle pouvait pas
se marier officiellement avec le roi
donc on les a fait une bière dur comme
elle est et brûlent une bière brune leur
personnalité c'est l'invitation de
madame voilà je mets donc en fait c'est
la bière préférée de stéphane bern et le
lorànt deutsch aussi bon et mick jagger
c'est sûr en tout cas on vous ramène une
pièce les gardiens c'est un petit peu en
proposait le deuxième à stéphane bern
stéphane bern ots mis le secret de louis
xiv voilà les secrets 14 ans le secret
14 le sucre et 14 je croise un coup de
fil à l'eau ainsi stéphane bern 50
caisses un service des fractures mais
raccroché mon émission quand même c'est
mon émission spéciale voilà merci à ses
débuts sur la télé je lis moi merci il
faut parler veut s'incruster tout bon
flow et amélie j'ai emmagasiné
suffisamment d'informations pour tricher
sur vous essayer de ramener la coupe à
la maison bonnet ou de france non
j'arrête ne vous enquiquiner avec les
chansons de championnat non mais tu nous
enquiquine pas way
we will to web alors on se quitte avec
oui
tout y est
notre hôpital et ben ouais je crois que
tu as raison dans le temps ça nous
éviterait livraison
[Musique]